oh we got a [ __ ]
uh we got a man over here hold on i got
a dude named am who looks like freaking
uh drago from uh game of thrones all
right what's up man
hey bro yeah carl drago sorry not
nitrogo carl drago all right man what do
you got for me tonight
you look like a man that probably
doesn't have any problems you know
having women look at you as an alpha
dude right
uh well i was actually can you hear me
all right just before i get started
you're good yeah go ahead yeah man cool
um to be honest i literally at the gym
and then i saw this and i was like what
the hell press one of the links now i'm
on here so brandon
but um to be fair i actually have um
a question i did i've seen like some of
your links and stuff and like your
videos before
um so
i was dating someone a while back and
that was like complete train wreck
didn't see any like the red flags that
were coming up and all that kind of
stuff like i'm quite i'm a lot younger
than i look i'm only in my mid-20s
and
i then ended up
as soon as
i was done with this girl i then moved
on straight away met someone new
and that's all been going well it's been
good but the issue i've had there's a
lot of similar red flags the main thing
for me
is kind of flakiness
it's like a girl who
like shows interest
because of
i guess like you know appearance and and
how you are as a person but then and for
me i do
so i'm a doorman um which is like a
bouncer um and then also run a security
firm and
coach and personal training and do kind
of a lot of jobs where women are kind of
surround
always around
um so it's kind of like there's interest
there but then
it's like oh we organize a date nothing
ever happens you know so physical
stuff's happening but just it's like
there's never any progress progress
there at all so i don't know what you're
looking for man like you know like
what's like what are you looking for
here girlfriend a wife like what are you
looking for i don't know man so i
was was all about that kind of
relationship [ __ ] before
um
and then
now i'm kind of like in that position
where i i ain't got no clue what i'm
doing with any about i'm very much
focusing like
career
physique
like that kind of stuff and you're how
old again you said what 24 25
i'm like 26 20 so okay so
i know everyone always thinks yeah and
of course because i work as a balancer
everyone's like oh you know look like
jason or whatever whoever else yeah
somebody said here in the chat that you
look like uh aquaman's little brother
yeah yeah exactly so
so a lot so women are flaking on you
yeah basically so it's like it's like
there's interest there like
physically no problem sleep you know
yeah physically so intimacy is no
problem you can bet them it's just
dating them doesn't doesn't go
it just takes ac but what do you think
that is
yeah what do you think that is if you
were to take a i guess
uh
i don't know i don't know really because
i don't even pursue pursue the girl they
always pursue me i'll get them asked for
my number i get asked do you want to
hang out like i get asked
and then then i chat to them they're all
good and then uh
then if it ever comes to organize
anything nothing ever ever comes with it
so i kind of just
i don't know bounce around really okay
so something like you
like you get to sex but you don't get to
dating
pretty much pretty much i never get any
further like so yeah okay i don't know
whether that should be something i
should be worried about whether it's
something to do with myself no no i can
tell you what it is dude it's like
you know again like you look like
aquaman's younger brother right like
like you have the look that you got the
ink you got the hair you got the muscles
how tall are you
uh six i'm six one but i wear boots all
the time sometimes you got the height
you got the security company you know
you're working in the [ __ ] uh
doors so i mean like you got a lot of
girls are all dressed up that see you as
like uh a man of authority like you're
like you're the gatekeeper you know you
decide if you know if they come in or
they don't come in you know sort of
thing or if they got to get removed from
the club sort of thing so
um they don't i mean like younger women
aren't generally going to see it as
long-term kind of material right or like
dating material they're going to see you
as a guide to bang you know it's like
you know rearrange their guts you know
have a good time
you know
um
you know it's a story that she tells her
girlfriends
um but i mean like why would you care
like at the end of the day i mean you
know if you're in your mid-20s
if if she's gonna flake on you she's
gonna flake on you i mean it doesn't
even seem like it's much work for you
anyway like you don't have to do much
work you know they're asking you for the
number they want to hook up
it's just you know you're not able to
get to spend more you know more like
time like dating time with them
yeah
i mean at the end of the day i mean a
lot of guys complain that women aren't
that particular like aren't particularly
interesting you know when it comes to
dating like they they have nothing to
you know really talk about in today's
world and i wouldn't really worry about
it you know to be honest with you do
your thing build the business you know
build the muscles grow the hair you know
get the stand in roll for the next
aquaman if you can get it sort of thing
but what i'm saying is is who [ __ ]
cares what women think
right you know if if they want to hang
out with you and and do stuff or travel
or whatever is it you're looking to do
it
i'll just boil it down to this okay
choose women that choose you
right
dealing with women shouldn't be hard
work it shouldn't be chasing him down
and why is she flaking on me if she's
flaking on you because she's a [ __ ]
flake you know she doesn't see you as a
guy that she wants to invest
on you know with a long-term basis she
just wants to ride the d have some fun
tell her girlfriends that she banged a
guy that looks like aquaman that can get
her in the door at the club sort of
thing that's fine you know
enjoy it but again choose women that
choose you over long-term basis you
don't have like
men and women are very different right
it doesn't matter if you have a notch
count of 10 or 100 or a thousand
okay it doesn't matter it's not like
you're broken if you slept with 100
women okay it's not like you have an
inability to pair bond with women women
struggle with that that's something that
women have a hard time with but it
doesn't affect men nearly the same way
that it affects women so it's not like
you have any risk exposure right like
like if you were my son i would have
that conversation with you if i was
talking to my daughter i'd be like look
you know your value is tied to
not being promiscuous you know your you
know your value is tied to preserving
you know who you are and not running
around the block you know sort of thing
so you know they're two different
conversations and again at your age
i don't even know why you're [ __ ]
about it where do you live do you live
in the uk still
yeah yeah i'm in the uk at the moment
but
um yeah we do work kind of all over the
place so some work abroad as well so i'm
out in middle east sometimes because
it's like close protection as well so
it's kind of yeah so i'm
in all over the place really sometimes
enjoy it man enjoy it like honestly
enjoy it like
you don't have any trouble getting girls
your problem sounds like it's getting
girls not to flake and to show up on
like a proper date so you can hang out
have a dinner and get to know them sort
of stuff and it's like you know what
again choose women that choose you you
know if you know she's gonna show up and
she's gonna want to
like
you know what chick's digging your vibe
on a long-term basis when she starts
asking you questions
which starts you know like wanting to
enter your world and like saying hey you
know what can i do to be useful you know
to you sort of thing right that's like
entering your frame and if she doesn't
choose to do that volunteer like you
shouldn't have to force her to do it you
shouldn't have to like coerce her you
shouldn't have to game her to do any of
that [ __ ]
it should be easy like relationship
should be fun and and easy and if it's
not then who cares you know like
you know like i've got i've got women
asking for my number every day at some
point you know like do you want to have
kids
i've got two and that's why i became
like the whole that's when i started
watching all these videos because i went
through
horrendous breakup with uh same mother
or do you have two mothers yeah same
mother i met a really young i hadn't had
my eldest well is is typical for this
area that i live in but my eldest is
nearly nine
so i'm super [ __ ] young
i live in a place called uh bracknell
which is like really common for like two
years pregnancy so no no i mean like i
lived in you know the uk when i was 21
22 for
for a bit and i was born there it's like
i saw a lot of young girls you know
pushing around prams with more than one
kid in them sometimes you know different
colors and everything like that
yeah um yeah it's it's you know the doll
is pretty common stuff like that but
yeah it's it's it's just like who
honestly dude like who cares
like stop stop caring you know so much
about women and why they're flaking
women will flake you don't have nearly
the same kind of problems that most guys
have like most guys are probably
watching this right now going [ __ ] me
this guy's complaining that you know you
know she's flaking on him but she but
but but like they're asking for his
number and they're you know like
basically jumping his bones voluntarily
he doesn't have to [ __ ] work for it
like give me a break bro shut up i don't
even want to hear this i can tell you
it's going to show up in the comments
tomorrow right so it's like you know
enjoy it and if you want to have more
kids or if you want to invite a woman in
your life do it after a proper vetting
period right like deal with her for a
couple years make sure she doesn't have
red flags make sure she you know she can
deal with stress you know when chaos you
know comes her way make sure she's a
compliment to your life make sure she
doesn't complicate it sort of thing
just don't worry so much about forcing
that on yourself you're very young man
you're a good-looking dude you obviously
have no problem you know attracting
women you know you've got pretty much
like all the [ __ ] like boxes ticked
off except for
most women look at you as the alpha seed
right now and that's cool you know
embrace it enjoy it and if you know
something turns into you know like an
ltr
be open to it if you want to but again
choose women that choose you make sure
there's no red flags and all the other
stuff that we talked about
you know you're solid dude
all right appreciate rich all right all
right see you there man thanks everyone
you